let's just start with the elephant words
right
why was it necessary for you to say that
anybody terena it couldn't beat the 700
player you write an insert as you know
well enough Charlie I've respect Serena
and very much so okay and I was simply
calling her on an NPR which supposedly
you're supposed you know this is the
where you can say it like it is and
you're gonna get honest feedback she's
the greatest player the female player
that ever lived then the lady said to me
I don't remember what's wrong but she
said why did you say woman why didn't
you just say the greatest you know
tennis player that ever lived
and so then I felt in need however
unfortunately I'm probably probably to
defend myself I don't know just say what
I really felt I mean which is about what
I think she would be I think you're
referring to the fact that I said she'd
be about 700 in the world yeah I've got
a solution Gayle though because I know
that you're friendly with Serena and I I
think I leave right now I'm just waiting
you would like to apologize
no the offer is this is because it seems
in tennis unlike other sports that
they're always asking about how women
they always ask me how I would do for
someone why is it this old bag John Mac
and okay how would he do against Serena
why don't you combine just solve the
problem I'm sure the men would be all
for this the men and women play together
and then we don't have to guess but John
you didn't answer Charley's question